Jeff I feel really bad for you we were
the most qualified to be President so if
you run again and hopefully you do you
can own all of it thank you dearly
beloved we are gathered here today to
commemorate the candidates that are no
longer with us the first candidate we'd
like to commemorate is John Alice Bush
Jeb we hardly knew ye it's too bad that
your policies couldn't find their way
out of the Republican morass sheds you
represent the oligarchy and I'm sorry as
a crazy race and you didn't make it
governor Bush i miss you i really wish
they were still in the campaign i was
rootin for you i really wanted a
candidate who believed in serious
educational reform i really appreciate
the fact that you spoke spanish so thank
you very much for making the effort lo
siento governor door Boosh what can we
say about Marco Rubio that hasn't
already been said he was called to many
things young charming
lil Marco the thing I'll miss most about
Marco Rubio is his fresh face I had
actually all my hopes pinned on you i
figured when the primary started the
fact that you were have a young
immigrant background was going to unite
the country and people were going to see
how much you represent today's America
medico okay no Arizona normal he seemed
like such a good conservative person
until he decided to get this a stupid
gang of eight amnesty bill that just
absolutely killed him I the candidate
some people died of gang violence he
died of gang of eight violence ben
Carson even though you were brain
surgeon you never quite knew what to do
with your hands i miss my moments with
ben we gently rocked me to sleep with
his lovely monotone voice well I liked
dr. Carson because he was unaffiliated
with politics as well as I am I think he
would have been a wonderful president
had he been a better public speaker
you're not a politician but you're a
great guy rust in peace
ok
what's happened Republicans what have
you done who's this guy you let hijack
your party I can't say I'll miss you but
I am super pumped to see what's gonna
happen next you lord have mercy